I'm joined by Yves and Thea from the
social minds podcast so what we're going
to talk about today millenials
millenials we have to if you believe
everything you've read if you fall into
that bracket you are lazy or
narcissistic you're probably not doing
very well for money you'll never be able
to afford a house eat too much avocados
toast
exactly being Millennials we feel that
Millennials are less defined by
situations around them stuff like 9/11
and whatever they're less defined by
these situations and more defined by
this room of innovation that's happened
between say 1982 to present they you
know what the finds of millennial is the
people who have lived through a vast
speed of technological change all this
media attention at Millennials getting
and the reputation that they've got just
refers to the snowflake generation which
people assume is like teens and
20-somethings yeah when it's actually
not so when I think the majority of the
time when people are saying all
millennial millennial they just mean
young people and they don't actually
realize it stretches up to the age of 38
ladies and gentlemen welcome back and
joined by Yves and Thea from the social
minds podcast here in my beautiful new
studio welcome hello back again well I
mean today it's an adopted studio only
this of course how are you good good
what your serene because I know how much
of a fan you are look at that especially
from Manchester as well of lasering yeah
it's a Manchester cake I suppose you
could call it a squidgy loaf
let me tell you about the difference
between a cake in a biscuit so cakes are
not that applicable biscuits are I don't
think the reason for that is that cakes
are not seen as a luxury item because
you would inevitably have to buy
birthday cakes presumably throughout the
year and Jaffa Cake I had to prove that
they were a cake and not biscuit to
avoid the tax the way that you prove
whether you're a biscuit or a cake is
cakes when they're left out go hard and
biscuits on the left out go soft burgers
from McDonald's have to have the pickles
in otherwise because of the amount of
sugar they would be classed as a cake
you kidding no yes but I think I heard
it off the guy who heard it off a guy
who a little guy whose brother take five
truth on the internet now which means it
so what we're going to talk about today
millenials millenials we have to we have
to talk about Millennials in a way that
we don't talk about Millennials at the
moment we need we need to see
Millennials differently basically and
well I suppose we could take it from the
beginning and the theory around at the
moment is that if you were born into
1982 or 1981 between then and 1996 let's
say you are classed as a millennial so
right now the oldest 38:37 the youngest
said
24:23 it depends on which definition you
look up as well which is another massive
issue because no one knows exactly where
the time line starts from where the time
line ends which is causing a lot of
confusion so it centers Bureau
starts at 1982 to 2000 and Pew Research
is 1981 to 1997 so the youngest
millennial could be 23 or 24 ships yeah
this one could be like 37 or 38 and no
one really knows where the boundaries
lie and if you believe everything you've
read if you fall into that bracket you
are lazy or narcissistic you're probably
not doing very well for money you'll
never be able to before the house eat
too much avocado toast exactly is all
these stereotypes that come along that
we you know whenever you see the word
millennial that you see and and it's and
it's as simple as that really and our
argument that this is that you know in
whatever context would you group the
sort of behaviors of a 38 year old or a
34 year old or whatever with that of
somebody 15 years younger than them
because that's how long the millennial
generation all span is is about 15 years
well I mean I definitely count towards
the top end I'm 31 and I would count
myself as a millennial but you are right
this seems to be a negative connotation
mmm so what what defines a millennial
then do you think in terms of their
behaviors in terms of what they how they
act and stuff like that this is this is
something that we've thought a lot about
and we've thought about in a way that if
you tell them an annual story
it's you've got this you've got this
group of people that fall into this
generation who have been affected by
major events so you've got things like
people will always list the financial
crash the list 9/11 I live there's stuff
like that and also the way parents have
been with their children that
Millennials are seen to be very there's
the term that goes around snowflakes
that we always use every day because
that's a good point you brought up about
like so things like the financial crash
in 9/11 the launch of the first iPhone
all happened right in the middle of the
Millennial time line so
meant to be a little bit more savvy with
career routes they don't follow the
traditional paths they're more likely to
go into entrepreneurship and things like
that
less likely to get married they're just
a little bit more easygoing in some
aspects than their than their parents
were exactly I'm not yet like you said a
bit narcissism and maybe a little bit
self-obsessed
and if we focus on that snowflake angle
and that it's always sort of tired with
Millennials it's basically because
you've shown you and a lot of your
listeners would have seen the video that
simon Sinek did and so he was a he still
is an oarfish I should say on YouTube
and he video say Millennials in the
workplace where for about 15 minutes
he basically tarde Millennials with this
brush and said they like this because of
this and one of the main points on that
was that Millennials are parents they
were very very safe of us you know they
wrap this up in sort of cotton wool and
we were given medals and trophies for
coming last because it's about the
participation that counts so you know if
you look at Millennials
the idea is that were very sort of you
know a little bit self effacing a very
much wrapped in cotton wool and we're
very kind of you know butter wouldn't
melt in some ways but you don't want to
you know every we take everything very
much to heart in a way so that's where
this whole snowflake idea comes from
there's a stereotypes though exactly yes
I'd like the the main problem is because
it spans like 15 to 18 years there's no
there's no way in hell all of those
people are the same like they're all
NASA sets or like none of them want to
get married or nitin like none of them
can afford a house like they are the
sweeping generalizations but the problem
is that like no other generation our
industry has sort of taken those
stereotypes as a gospel and because they
don't understand the generation because
no one really knows like what they want
or how to speak to them they take the
stereotypes as gospel and they're using
them to target them but they're just
completely wrong yeah so we've got well
we've we've we've got a completely
different take on it in a way and that
is you know probably skipping forward a
little bit but it's we feel that
Millennials you know that be
we feel that Millennials are less
defined by the situation's around him
stuff like 9/11 and whatever they're
less defined by these situations and
more defined by this boom of innovation
that has happened between say 1982 to
present day really so if we can list it
off we read the first Nokia phone I
remember it came in the mid 90s and then
from there was you know he took way
before the iPhone putting cameras into
phones was a massive thing then video
phones came and then you go on from
there and you've got stuff like Windows
dial-up broadband so we said every year
you can remember it like we're probably
all about the same age where we can
literally remember a world before all
that and so we watched it happen like
the little year year on yeah I was a
little bit younger I think I went into
secondary school when I got my first
flip phone and I remember my sister
getting enough here when I was still in
primary school and being really really
jealous because her and her friends were
playing snake and I wasn't allowed but
yeah like literally every single year
after that that when I was in year 8
someone brought in the first iPhone 3
and everyone was like cooing over that
by the next year everyone had iPods and
then that big thing social media
happened yeah halfway through that so to
sort of answer your question in kind of
a succinct way it is you know what the
finds of millennial is the people who
have lived through a vast speed of
technological change the resident
rockety exactly unprecedented and it's
that's the you know there's stats to
sayin and sort of opinions around that
there's been more innovation in the last
five years that now has in the last 30
years believe that to some extent
because if we take you know yeah Stan
forget about pre 99 if we take you know
let's take 1995 let's sort of say dial
up as we remember it the period between
that and present day has seen
unprecedented change absolutely in
technology I mean the world is evolving
faster than our minds can to cope with
it it's evolving faster than our
social causes our understanding of how
society works our laws like to be
whoever a lawmaker is if that was I
don't know how it works I'm gonna guess
it'll be the sort of thing which is
actually done through the government but
if you're a private firm that was able
to write laws as new technologies come
along like you're probably one of the
richest companies in the world like all
you had to do is go oh my god first we
have to work out what's happening with
this internet thing yeah oh [ __ ] now
they've got it in their pocket oh my god
neither downloading music illegally I
mean it's just this monster that's grown
so many different limbs so have you read
the coddling of the American mind no so
that book is about is seminal by
Jonathan hate it's about a seminal for
what you're talking about now and as you
can get and for anyone who is listening
go back and listen to Jonathan hate on
Joe Rogan fantastic podcast and he talks
about links between depression and
anxiety and suicide in young girls and
the advent of social media there's this
line around about 2008 and then another
one around about 2012 where there's
marked differences in behavior and stuff
like that but one thing that you
mentioned was to do with the awards for
coming last this participation is kind
of coddling right that's what Jonathan
refers to it us and personally for me as
someone who was born in 88 I never saw
any of that mmm I feel like I and I
didn't hear about any of that until four
or five years ago so I think lumbering
the Millennials as they are as they've
been defined by the studies that you
guys have looked at into the snowflake
generation I think is erroneous like for
me there was there was none of that so a
perfect example of this is where you
said people become hypersensitive they
take a lot of things to heart if you
have a look at purposefully exposing
children who have a predisposition to
allergies two types of treats that have
peanut just coat
mmm-hmm you reduced the chance of them
having anaphylaxis in later life by 25
to 50% what that means is that if you
purposefully expose young children to a
small dose of something which
potentially is uncomfortable for them
later in life they benefit mmm what it
means is that by the the same thing goes
for those high rates of asthma in
cleaner households if you disinfect the
[ __ ] out of your house Saxons yes yeah
whereas you go to places like Africa
almost no asthma because the houses
expose children to low doses of what it
is that is going to protect them later
in life you're not meant to wash
everything that you give to a newborn
baby no I've had new parents are always
like oh my god make sure everything's
really clean mentally you meant to leave
some germs on their immune system
socially the same thing occurs right
this is but this is exactly it at the
root of this problem is this need to put
these conditions on what we call
Millennials I mean you know let's make
no bones about it it's very easy to use
the term Millennials and stuff like
marketing and and you know when a market
is trending exactly it's also you know
we can and we and we do define
demographics you know in the same way
that you've got Gen X's you've got
boomers the problem seems to be with the
focus on Millennials under the spotlight
and that is setting a precedent for we
were speaking about it in terms of that
you know now that we've done the whole
millennial thing let's call it that and
we've sort of you know what do they want
what they like why do they feel the idea
shot exactly yes and all of that and
grouping sixteen year olds you know what
it would have been back then grouping
sixteen year olds with 34 year olds and
saying they are exactly the same so you
know if you've got people at the start
of their you know before they were you
spend in power and they're going to
university you've got people who're you
know you're taught you put you're
telling me you're putting them in the
same boat as people who were 34 two kids
two dogs mortgage exactly when you said
before about so there's millennial
stereotypes which you say don't apply to
you maybe because you run the older end
of that spectrum and then
the snowflake generation but I think the
problem is that the entire general
public and it may be like it's not so
bad in the marketing industry because if
if you know it then that you know we're
putting it to good use we know what the
actual boundaries are but all this media
attention that Millennials are getting
and the reputation that they've got just
refers to the snowflake generation which
people assume is like teens and
20-somethings yeah when it's actually
not so when I think the majority of the
time when people are saying all
millennial millennial they just mean
young people and they don't actually
realize it stretches up to the age of 38
yeah especially seen as like me and Dom
were discussing this earlier on there is
a an equivalent of a self-awareness
menopause that you go through between
the age of around about 22 and sort of
30
some people never go through it but the
majority of people do tend to go through
it Dom said when he was 23 and he was
sober going out his friends would give
him grief when he's 26 and so about his
friends look at him with admiration
because there is this flipping of
consciousness from the egocentric to the
more mature hmm and the there is a
formative the formative years as they're
referred to the end of that like the
final boss is a reduction in ego yeah
aren't for most people if you have a I
guess a healthy progression we could see
that yeah and what that means is that we
and the other thing as well millennial
is such a it's just such a buzzword II
term yeah
it's the sort of thing that you can
throw out yeah and now it is Jen's ed
yeah like probably most people that read
the news that pick a typical person on
the street in Manchester and most people
are going to know what a millennial is
yes yeah like young young people yeah
okay we've said Jen's ed to be like is
that a new computer game like is that if
this is it and this this is one of the
this is another one of the interesting
byproducts of the millennial generation
is that because you know if I could see
it from my point of view and I'd imagine
many others because there was so much
emphasis on working out Millennials what
makes them tick that was
the headlines you'd say what makes them
tick what do they actually want that
we've used this as a precedent to
question jens even to the point where we
see reports questioning jen a now
technique Janae's about probably seven
five years old and we're already making
assumptions about what they're like the
kind of world they would grow up with
we've got the world of augmented reality
virtual reality voice well we don't want
the same mistakes to happen again that
happened with the millennial generation
where you know we spent stolen trying to
figure them out that by the time we've
actually figured it out we were already
on the back burner suspending Jared yeah
they are old like there's another one or
a red se but I think we're making a
mistake there because like we were
saying earlier about the speed of
innovation that happened in the
Millennial time line is not going to
happen again it's already slowed if you
look at before the millennial generation
innovation was more invention and it was
quite slow you know the computer the
first Apple Mac and then all of a sudden
it was like boom boom boom new products
for consumers and now it's like okay now
we're expecting voice to kick off for
expecting VR to do the same thing but
it's not going that quickly it's it's
taken a little bit of a dip yeah I don't
think it'll have the you know the same
the same effect as any old generation
did do you think it's been like a real
state shift through the millennial
generation and now it's just different
flavors of the same cake yeah it was so
hard to figure out because nothing like
that had ever happened before or the new
technology that came and that's what
shaped their mindset and opinions like
slap bang in the middle so I older
Millennials differ so much from younger
Millennials because if you grow up with
the influence of a smartphone in social
media you know you can't underestimate
the offending that's going to have on
you yeah you could you could put a you
know you could get a empty room and put
a bit of masking tape down down the
landing room and say right everybody
born in the 20th century standing on
this side of the room everybody's drawn
on 21st century stand on this side of
the room or oh sorry I should say
anybody you sort of grew up formatively
in the 21st century stand on this side
of the room and that is what we are that
is what we were looking at and like love
you said you know we've covered briefly
on the innovations app and just to sort
of reiterate that I mean
okay so we had smartphones so sorry
let's start second beginning we had
mobile phones you know the bricks back
then in the million Arne CARLMAN
exactly yeah that you know and they were
still up wires and we still call them
mobile phones yeah
and then you add camera phones and you
add video phones and your MP freeze sony
sony eric so well so we've got this
innovation it's happening rapidly in
communication which you know extends to
broadband social media because let's not
forget you know before facebook and
instagram
it was Bebo and myspace and and whatnot
and it was all of that so while all this
is going on you've got changes in media
so dvd/vhs which became blu-ray and then
audio as well so it's all you know this
this rapid period of change is what has
shaped this generation the problem when
we talk about Millennials is we always
talk about a disconnect between
Millennials and brands or Millennials
and other generations you know we put
the spotlight on and we sort of push
them into the the sort of corner of the
room and say you are this this this is
this because of this and I think
essentially like like we put what we're
saying is that it's not you know it's
not about for the millennial generation
had 9/11 we had atrocities like 9/11 Gen
X had you know the invasion of
Afghanistan they fall of the Berlin Wall
you know before that we had world wars
the Vietnam War
every every generation has their sort of
societal kind of catastrophes financial
crashes what whatever it doesn't I've
you know a cease to believe that that
place such a part in the Millennial
construct as it does the Gen X contract
as it does fairly have a generation they
agree and how you are yeah I do agree I
think um when you're talking about
Millennials and you lump them in a
corner
it does it does hark a little bit as
like a derogatory term mmm which is
really just which is probably not not
very nice like considering that that's
where you come from and that Simon's
neck thing it will be in the show notes
below the video that you're talking
about you just lamb busts anyone who's a
part of that group and says that you've
got this incredibly kind of
transactional value that everyone
very easy come easy go like that they
treat careers like they treat tender and
like swiping left and right on and
there's something about there's
something that romanticizes the old ways
that things are done like having a job
for life staying with a part of their
life I did a podcast with Daniel schloss
Netflix comedian and we talked about he
talked about the fact that back in your
parents generation you would have only
known you know apart from the people at
work it maybe you'd only known 50 people
that you'd have had a connection with 50
people hmm so really like if you were
having a bad time with your partner like
you got to stick it out and make it
works you don't know where the [ __ ]
anyone else is like wonderful where am I
going to find an alternative the I don't
know like there's no one else at church
yeah like and that's it and you like
life isn't on a church I'm screwed so
the same thing occurs for that but
obviously one of the one of the key
factors has been the this serendipitous
communication where you you have a
greater reach that's always on hmm and
what that's enabled people to do is to
be able to they're emancipated and
they're freed from the previous
constraints geographically temporarily
as well like you can speak to someone
who's in America who's in Australia's
got instant communication all these sort
of things and it's allowed people to be
freed from the previous confines that
they had but also we don't we don't know
what that we didn't know what that meant
for people we didn't know what it was
going to enable people to be able to do
and there was no model that was
pre-written
so you're right like it does feel a
little bit like the old guard that
usually the people that push the
Millennials have a poor degree a poor
moral compass rhetoric yeah that old
guard that are pushing it honest with
the people that were supposed to guide
us through it exactly yeah and they
didn't you know like okay was there a
point at which social media came along
where you came before Instagram and said
you should maybe stick to trying to post
virtuous and in things that represent
your integrity as opposed to displaying
your life in a way there is a highlight
reel hmm no one ever said that to me no
no one ever said you should
from the beginning that you have a
smartphone consider your time and your
attention and look at the cognitive
tricks that are being played on you no
one ever said that to me either like you
know it took ages for the Internet to be
around for people to even start to talk
about like chat services like MSN for
being like an area that children should
be safe around yes yeah are you like you
know I it does feel a little bit like
the people that pushed the narrative of
Millennials are this kind of the squalor
sewage of low virtue narrative are they
were the people that were supposed to
guide ones who raised it yeah absolutely
like you all that you're doing basically
it's Frankenstein's monster like you
were supposed to be the people that
helped us through this and on top of
that as well like it sounds it just
smacks massively of bitterness I think a
lot of the youth every single generation
would look at the generation below them
and thank what are these ones doing now
I you know the people who are younger
than us the only difference I think with
Gen X's opinion of Gen Y to Jim wise
Millennials Gen Xers opinion of Gen Y
has spread out to everyone so now even
Millennials like criticizing other
Millennials like their peers I have
friends who they probably know that they
are in the Millennial Generation but
they'll go oh I'm not millennial I'm not
like that I'm not a snowflake I don't go
out for brunch mmm that and that kind of
stuff and it's like what you're actually
stereotyping yourself and actually you
are a Millennials and we're talking
about this over I take a hard-line
stance on this in a way because I feel
you know it's excited this if we want to
use the word Millennials sparingly but
young people at this time of
technological change this was an
exciting time and this was us finding it
out for ourselves it was like you know
your parents generation or their parents
generation discovering rock and roll
this was our rock and roll moment it was
like
I could be anybody I want to be and post
on my Facebook post on my people and do
whatever now the problem I see with from
my own observations with the millennial
generation is that past generations have
been able to define who they are
themselves in a sense so we think about
Gen X Gen Xers about Gen X is the you
know they're the alternative generation
it was MTV and it was this and that now
Millennials they've sort of had this
label just put put on and pushed on and
you know unwillingly and and that's sort
of stuck to the point that you know a
millennial can we can't shift this
reputation that's been put on us you
want to sit up with boomers your own set
up with Gen X I doubt you'll see with
the generation that comes after Gen
Zed's come like so separated from their
own generation because they feel like
these labels and these stereotypes have
been put on them again so well no one
wants to be categorized against that
well yeah everyone like we like
belonging to groups don't we we feel you
know affinity used to certain like
nationalities or a football team hair
color but all of a sudden like someone
tells you oh you're a millennial which
means you're this this this and that has
to go wait a minute why are demographers
deciding who I am so a lot of people
have yeah the irony of it in advertising
is that the disconnect with this
generation in a sense has come from the
fact that it's not about you know let's
find out who they are it's about let's
find out who they are among ourselves
everyone's talking about them and
there's not a millennial in sight and
they're all over there watching go what
some guy some guy in a smoking jacket
sat on a Chesterfield sofa somewhere
yeah telling that like accusing people
of not having any moral virtue and and
being snowflake yeah you are totally
right but the worst thing is they say
that the best lies are the ones that
have some truth in them and there is
degrees of truth like we all know that
friend yes who
treats relationships and their career
very transactionally has junk values and
doesn't spend enough time outside like
the and it's the fact that there are
elements of truth but by exaggerating it
by exaggerating this rhetoric it means
that everybody can cast it off and say
well that's not me yeah because it's so
overblown that even the most cutting and
accurate statement will still have a
couple of bits that don't apply to you
yeah and that doesn't help people to
understand themselves and it's why I
think one of the reasons potentially why
are you seeing this resurgence now of
introspective work of the the headspace
meditation Sam Harris is waking up and
you know next door to the offices that
we're in is the Manchester Buddhist
compassion center yeah where you can go
and meditate it's like that's city
centre Manchester right next to a trendy
office and all this sort stuff because I
think that when people are being
dictated poor values about themselves
that they don't think that they align
with it's very messy signals and what
they're trying to do is work through
okay well maybe I am this or hang on and
then before you know it you have to go
away and find out yourself mm-hmm
yeah I think what's really bad like a
bad side effect of that it's especially
for our industry is what a lot of
marketers and brands haven't realized is
that all of that his bread like a
subgroup of this generation of people
who actively do the opposite of what
their generation is stereotyped to do so
people who are of the Millennial age but
don't use social media the people who
you know started buying vinyl records
and they'll do things very sustainably
and they'll act similarly to how their
grandparents it because that's the new
cool and it's like the people targeting
this age group are doing so by like the
majority of the stereotypes and actually
there's a really really large portion of
it of them that are acting completely
oppositely yeah because they don't want
to be tarred with the same brush but
there is a caveat to all of this as well
when that is at the whether we like it
or not these stereotypes still work yeah
in advertising and I know this was
something you touched on in a past
episode Chris I think we've
Rory Sutherland and let's take one
campaign for instance the a lot of
people I'm sure would have seen it the
British Army's campaign that you know
snowflakes we want you and that when
that went around play on the Lord
Kitchener Staters they they did and it
was that the after they broadcast this
advert there you know it was appealing
to the gamer who stays up for 48 hours a
time and these people you know your your
agility your endurance the army actually
found that their recruits doubled within
a month they surprisingly hated the
campaign there's a massive backlash to
this campaign snowflakes we want you to
join the army
you know come to the army we need
Millennials and it worked and yeah I
mean theory it's one of the circular mad
things about advertising right like that
you can do something that's inflammatory
so I have no idea I would love for to
see Gillette in whenever their next
earnings goes yeah afternoon after they
did the the most recent advert and it is
going down that risky route of kind of a
meta cognizant look at what culture is
and the manipulation of culture by it
like a culture for cultures sake almost
looking at with a pure bird's-eye view
it's a high-risk strategy and like
that's evidently worked but then you
think okay so it's doubled recruit but
what's it done for the British Army's a
standing in society as a whole
long term is that potentially going to
be some downstream effects of this that
are a little bit more negative than
might not be so clever and then the
Gillette thing as well I'm sure that sat
round that boardroom table someone said
and maybe half the room would have gone
yes I love it men are going to really
connect with this on a deeper level and
it could have gone well but it got 10 to
1 ratio of dislikes to likes on YouTube
so what does that say
I don't know guy I don't know what
that's translated to in terms of sales
but yeah the manipulation of the matter
narrative about Millennials is a
dangerous game to play what do you
think's gonna happen as we move forward
then with Gen zet because that's is that
people after 96-98
said they say 96-97 yeah born after that
so maybe all these gens that about
coming up to 20 to 22 or 23 depending on
your definition said there's like a few
different research things Wow um just
just to just to add on that the us an
organization in the US only class only
really recognized boomers as a official
generation as an official demography
MERS just the and that what the word
boomers comes from that everybody was
having kids after what after the World
War they said this was the population
boom these are the boomers evil um so 50
years of people in together exactly
being someone being born today and
someone that's 50 years old yeah you can
see the floor in the system to answer
your question for generations Ed I don't
know what's gonna happen but what we're
trying to make happen and what we hope
will happen is basically learning from
the mistakes that were made with the
millennial generation we don't want to
assume that just because let's say a
group of people
spanning 15 to 18 years exactly the same
just because of their age so what
marketers should be focusing on now is
their mindsets and their behavior so if
you look at things like Facebook pixels
ability to track absolutely everything
you do based on a click based on a
purchase based on you cookies they know
everything whether it is your plans for
the weekend or you know what play you
want to see next week they know
absolutely everything and when there's
that much detail out there that tells
you you know who your customers are and
what they're doing why are we still
paying attention to how old they are
like that says anything about the way
that they act in a way that they behave
like we can still we can still use
demographics loosely but the point is
it's not the most important thing that
we should be focusing on
oh yeah there's a greenways there's
still a place for age definitely in
marketing and there will be that I think
you know what we're talking about what
is that focus on targeting more narrowly
on me
it's like don't just blanket target
everyone don't pay attention to
stereotypes it's all about your unique
audience and age will always play a part
but I don't think it should be the most
fun but for me the wide of the wider
femurs well with Gen Z is I to answer
the question as well I don't think
there's gonna be much change I think
we're all you know as a society this
goes outside of marketing and
advertising I think we're waiting for
Gen Z to be completely different and
they're gonna be this and they're gonna
be that and they're there but you'll see
a lot of the traits that you know
supposedly in Gen Z cross over to the
Millennial traits you know they are
entrepreneurial they are ambitious
of course animation has slowed so we
what we were saying yesterday if you
know how we're saying earlier about
every year for the Millennials there's a
different piece of technology now every
single iPhone regeneration or Samsung
depending on if your Android or iPhone
every single through generation is
pretty much the same they just
recharging a lot more often like not
much innovation because even they have
no room to grow the biggest software
hardware companies are forced to just
slow down the old models so that you buy
the new ones because there just isn't
that much like innovation is happening
it's just not happening as quickly as it
was before so when we expect generations
ed to be completely different to us
we're assuming that something massive is
going to happen like another another
digital revelation and it's just not the
case yeah no you are right that's a
really really good point
I think social media was a I guess you
could call it a technological revolution
but it was unexist inquiry mm-hm but
certainly for me one of the things that
I am most concerned about and as a good
avatar for someone who's regularly in
contact with people are 18 to 21 and
some of them I'm heavily heavily
invested in especially our managers that
work for who do events I want them to be
the most efficient
the best that they can be not only for
the fact that it makes us more money and
but also just that I take personal pride
in creating these monsters of their age
who go out into the workforce and just
walk all over everybody else because
they've had this crash course in
intensity on how to be efficient and how
to behave and how to have discourse with
professionals and customers knowledge
sort stuff um and what I see from a lot
of them is that social media forget the
technology of Technology was simply the
root it was the delivery mechanism for
the virus but the virus itself was
social media and I know that that's an
inflammatory term to use for it there's
a lot of good that comes from social
media but I think that for the vast
majority of people at least at the
moment I think it's netting a negative I
think that one of the podcasts have done
recently someone analyzed at analogized
instagramers swimming through sewage
looking for a diamond know you have this
serendipitous connection with people and
once every couple of months you might
make a really really good connection and
you like that's exactly why I do it but
to gamblers fallacy and it's like how
much cost have you sunk into this in
order to turn this around and you think
well can I have my cake and eat it too
can I have the serendipitous connection
and have the things that I want which is
keeping up to date with my family and
knowing the real stuff whilst evading
all of the sewage and I think that that
overall situation that environment for
people formative people's formative
years to be growing up in I know
certainly and it may be different for
yourselves they are know that you're a
little bit less on your phone as than I
am but for me certainly my capacity to
be able to read and focus on a book
which is low stimulus has verses eleven
years old to now it is so much less like
a so hard to sit there and not even just
not fidget because my body is
conditioned to a particular level of
stimulus the a piece of paper with non
moving words that are in black and white
it can't match up with and it's been the
last year's base
you've been spent on a morning
retraining myself to be able to sit and
look at something that's not triggering
dopamine every couple of seconds you
know so on our our most recent episode
of social Minds we had a guest in from
Iceland with the CBT therapist called
dr. feel that held the doctor she was
telling us about some research that came
out in January that actually says you
know we always say that social media is
causing depression it's earned that
reputation because there's been like an
uplifting reports of people more people
being diagnosed and half of that's
because more people are aware that it's
happening they're more open about you
know reporting it like going to the
doctor's and and a half of it probably
has to do with social media but she said
that what they found is that people were
more likely especially young girls were
more likely to turn to social media when
they were already diagnosed with
depression so it wasn't actually there's
a correlation that for sure but social
media wasn't actually the cause it was
the symptom yeah coping mechanisms yeah
definitely but like he was saying about
being able to you know stop and focus
and read a book that I've noticed that
myself it because you're so used to just
being switched on all the time and then
dr. Fuhrer actually said that it's very
important for our brains to have idle
time like we need to be bored for the
brain to develop properly especially in
young people that we just need time to
do nothing and it's something that no
one gets these days because we just
don't know about you but I feel guilty
when I'm doing nothing I just sat there
because you're expected to switched on
the rhetoric that's been pushed and I
mentioned on the podcast I did with Tom
you mentioned Gary Gary Vaynerchuk and
Gary if you're still listening first off
I'm very surprised after what I said
about but then on top of that as well
like the hustle and grind mentality
mixed with always-on communication is a
dangerous combination like
industriousness can be taken to an
extreme now flow by me hey I'll check me
hi oh that's my difficult one together
in the book flow what he talks about is
the fact that human beings have the
greatest sense of satisfaction
when they are doing something which
pushes them physically or mentally and
is both challenging and worthwhile so
those are the things that you need to be
able to do you push yourself to the
limits of your competence doing
something challenging and worthwhile
mm-hmm and that's why he says that
people who have a propensity towards
being industrious if I'm going away on
holiday very difficult because at work
you have inherent challenge you have a
feedback mechanism that tells you how
well you're doing and you have goals
those are the three main things that you
need on holidays just completely
unstructured like you don't win an award
for being the best sunbather or like I
think that this is why a lot of people
when they go away on holiday especially
young guys who feel like they have
something to prove will turn towards
some form of game who can drink the most
drinks tonight who can like kiss the
most girls tonight or like girls could
do it in a slightly more different way
where it's like who looks the best
tonight who's got the the nicest dress
who's got the best like how many
landmarks can we hear in one day yeah do
you know I mean because you want to try
and provide this sort of structure but
obviously what happens when you have
what could be maneuvered towards a very
virtuous goal which is I'm gonna
constantly be looking at assessing
myself and finding out where I can
improve and this not any other it's very
easily twisted and bastardized into
constant self-reflection with negative
mind talk inability to switch off and a
desire to always have stimulus like if
you go I think the the study that I
heard recently was that 75% of people
take their phone to the toilet and the
only thing I could think was I can't
believe it that low like here's what you
do when you're on the toilet like yeah
but it shouldn't be and the time the
time on your own is is super super
important deep work by Cal Newport is
the Bible on this we'll be doing a book
review on deep work and digital
minimalism coming up soon but if you
want to check it out the link will be to
the Amazon shop in the show notes below
but deep works just the Bible on this
about the fact that it is
psychologically neurologically and
philosophically a good thing to do to
focus on one task for a significant
period of time and it's a skill that's
increasingly being missed in the 21st I
think it's just like common sense so
that's why we're being ogled by older
generations because they can say like
the what's gone wrong I agree with this
to an extent but I feel and Israel
coined the generations again I feel this
bastardization of social media
well well relevant at times I feel this
is the same as sort of saying you know
the counter-argument so that will always
be well you know the people who are on
their phones 24/7 are gonna make them
work the best coders in ten years time
when it matters and stuff so and while I
agree with the fact that maybe there is
less of a focus on books I feel it's
still you know the medium of getting
information and getting knowledge has
changed and I think one of the things
that we do are open eyes to a campaigns
and you know in all sort of areas is
that social media you know fall it's
wrong has allowed us to act in a
meaningful way if you can take it at
face value there is the whole sort of
narcissistic element to it you know you
see influencer marketing in the end you
sort of think God you know narcissism
assitant narcissism but I'd have to
question that without social media would
we be as in tune to the world would we
care as much about the environment would
we be would we get to this point now
where we are so you know that sense of
connection with society where we are so
aware so hyper aware of that there are
many different walks of life however
people feel I think it's I think as you
know well well you could look at the
person on the bus who's just looking in
their phone I forget as tennyson's a
better communicator the way made us more
I use as well I think we are becoming
more aware to the mistakes that we've
maybe made like you said like we were
failed like by our parents or by the
people who created this technology no
one educated us on safe use of it and
now we're sort of getting to grips a bit
teaching ourselves and I like to think
of it like a car like the first car like
how long was it before they got
seatbelts in store
and like you wouldn't you wouldn't deal
would you you need to learn how to drive
the car you need to you know put your
safety measures in like I know if I'm
gonna feel [ __ ] about myself I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna follow people who
are posting things that are gonna make
me feel [ __ ]
you just have to curate your feets and
know how to use it and turn to it for
positive things and like it can be so
helpful for your productivity and like
you said awareness about so many causes
we just have to train ourselves to use
it for good I think I think young people
I think young people definitely do I
think it you know it turns a question
the way that as well is I think a
characteristic of Jen's Eddie it's funny
the irony of is become a very millennial
thing to say you kids you know you're
addicted to social media all you do is
watch you know youtubers and wrapping
toys and who wants to do that he played
with fidget spin is what you're doing
and that's that in itself has almost
become a kind of millennial trait so we
had just you know going I mean to go on
to what you said about the about the car
analogy it's perfectly correct and what
really there should be given for people
who were the patient zero avatars for
the advent of all of these technologies
where the technology came before the
best practices for healthy you stood and
before the legislation did mmm-hmm
we should be giving compassion there
should be a degree and I I feel that
myself like I have because for me my
mobile phone was a conduit for my
business which meant that I started to
get into the rhythm of using it and then
the tactics which are used by particular
social media apps to keep you on
infinite scroll auto playing videos red
notifications etc etc I've now become a
victim of those particular cognitive
tricks and I'm now having to undo the
work that was done but if you're someone
who's coming through in Jen's ed skrein
time on an iPhone only came out six
months ago mmm way where it allows you
to track the time you've spent on
individual apps if you haven't got it
turned on I urge you to do so just so
that you can have a look go into your
settings have a look at screen time and
it'll be very revealing it's to where
you're talking crazy revealing right
but then so perfect example here and
this is within the same window right
we're talking the same device did you
have an iPhone when you needed to
download an app that allowed you to use
a flashlight so you didn't it wasn't
always in the dock at the bottom you
needed to download an app or your hands
and turn your video camera on with the
flash activated yeah and then it took
them a while to realize hang on this is
something which people need this is a
feature which we need to add you think
now like why would you not swipe up from
the bottom attorney flashlight on
whereas in the past you had to scroll
find like flashlight app do i io s yeah
press that and then it was like a little
flashlight and you press that so even
within the window that were talking
about of technology we have seen
something come about which was needed
and then be internalized by the company
that creating the technology and the
same thing is occurring with social
media that it was this monster that to
come about and before you know Tristan
Harris and the he men said that some of
the human technology and all of this
movement towards understanding what the
attention economy is and how it
manipulates people that's only just
starting to catch up with what's
actually being going on everyone's
playing to catch up and you're so right
it's because the innovation comes before
the rules around it like people are
constantly playing catch-up it's oh
here's a new thing okay we've got to
regulate that and here's something else
and now we have to put rules on that
which is constantly catching up with
yours although I don't necessarily think
that's a bad thing sometimes I think
it's that experimentation patience and I
like to compare it to literally anything
that we've invented it's always hard
floors and it's always had dangers
before people figure out oh actually
that we need to amend that bit and we'll
make changes here and make it better
it's literally like anything else yeah
so yeah no I don't think it's a bad
thing I rules have been put in place
beforehand if someone was able to
predict all this is gonna be this big
thing that's going to come along and
change everything and it's gonna like
make people sad and light
their intention steal their data they'll
be like okay that's not allowed to
happen
yeah and we wouldn't be where we are
without so much on the social point I
want to throw something at you Chris
how much of that manipulation you know
of social media how much of the
development innovation whatever you want
to call it how much does that you think
is placed on it by the platforms and how
much of it do you think is just us as a
society sort of placing our own needs
and wants and desires on this technology
it's been able to like believing that
the technology is an Oracle or some
panacea exactly all of our plans I
because of where my mindset is at the
moment I do have quite a negative view
of Silicon Valley and what they've done
with regards to manipulating
technologies anyone who has read much of
Tristan Harris's work will understand
just how subversive and malicious some
of the strategies are that people have
been used the guy that created infinite
scroll says it's a single greatest
regret of his life yeah mm-hmm
because you think about just how many so
a perfect example of this have you seen
the film The Big Short no parts of it on
the film on the film the big shot it's
about the 2008 financial crisis crash it
is a it's a fictional adaptation of what
actually happened and in it this guy
says that before he came to work on Wall
Street he built bridges and he said he
worked out a built this particular
bridge which shortened a very highly
congested route and over the lifetime of
this bridge which was about 100 years
he'd saved billions of hours for people
that's how long it saved and I often
think about what converse has been done
through social media hmm and he think
right okay like if you were to look at
how much time has been spent on that and
again there are positives which come out
of it but in in my belief we are netting
and negative and the problem is that in
10 years time I believe that there will
be
more control in place that may either be
in terms of best practices that are
socially enforced that may be in terms
of legislation that may be in terms of
the way that the platforms actually self
manage and self-regulate or whatever it
might be but the problem is that
Millennials and Gen Zed they've been the
canary in the coal mine for this so
they've been the people that have gone
in first they're the Vanguard that their
point they're on point in this
particular invasion into a new realm of
technology that no one's ever seen
before
and I think that really calls for a lot
more compassion for some of the problems
that people are dealing with like my mum
and dad don't have a problem with social
media like my dad's got the largest
fossil reader my dad's got the largest
font available on his phone and he loves
to send me photos of the dogs and stuff
like that but like I have no concerns
about whether or not my dad is up on
Facebook until on YouTube until 2:00 in
the morning yeah but my business
partners two-year-old son who has a
Amazon Kindle to watch Despicable Me on
I get nervous when I see him around it
hmm because I think I wonder downstream
and I'm constantly like tapping on Darin
in Killeen business partner and his wife
about like make sure you're being
careful
like the unbelievable parents and but I
it's a powerful technology that I think
we need yeah got to be careful as we
move forward to it I think one positive
thing that will come out of that like my
my sister's recently had a baby and
she's the same she's always asking me
like Oh like when when should we let
this child come you know an iPad could
you see them that they like playing with
iPads and so when did they get their
first phone like should they be allowed
social media when they're like
pre-teenage and it's one of them like
you're right like we went in first we're
definitely the guinea pigs
patient zero exactly but hopefully we'll
have something then to learn from and
we'll just have to like anything else
teach our kids how to use it how to use
it responsibly to use it in moderation
mmm like reap its rewards without I
don't have you I don't be a Luddite
about this either I don't to be saying
like the
there are fantastic benefits but at what
cost and can we mitigate the costs and
to look back you know we spoke about
people that had gone to war wasn't that
long ago that there was conscription
into the army hmm no I'm complaining
about the fact that this Oracle of all
knowledge in my pocket that's always on
and allows me to connect with anyone at
any time
sometimes saps my attention like I'm
aware that there is it relatively across
all of time probably not that big of a
problem yeah but as we close towards
what we want to be an ideal society we
need to narrow down the fidelity in the
resolution at which we're looking at the
problems so saying but it was this is
much better than it was fifty years ago
there isn't an argument how much better
could it be because if you're comparing
stuff to how it was fifty years ago me
doing what your census people did and
you're just lumbering all of this not
only all of the people but the entirety
of the world yeah companies publish your
on your profits they don't publish like
century on century profits because it
wouldn't be comparable yeah I think it's
interesting I think we are you know and
going back to that point about Jen's ed
I think we are starting to see I don't
say pulling the reins on innovation a
little bit but like we said where
there's been so much technological
change I mean the innovations we talked
about nowadays are very much to do with
artificial intelligence and stuff like
that you know which has been around for
a lot longer than we think and for me a
very big difference with that is they
are not as consumer-facing
as social media once was
I suppose it's you know know everyone's
not going around saying oh I'm just
doing a new AI thing old man have you
seen this this is AI you know it's it's
it's less and less so like that yes it's
being served to us in more sort of
guerilla ways you know chuck bots and
stuff like that but no I do agree with
your point I've for me I feel you know
someone else at represent Gen Z and
definitely Gen a is just like we became
the sort of
arey you know in the coal mines you can
say we we found a way to regulate this
ourselves I think and I think that's
that's not that's not what we must not
get away from too much is that yes
there's gonna be casualties is gonna be
a lot of problems with this but I think
Jen's ed and Janae's greatest benefit
will be then finding their way into the
world and regulating this technology how
they want it to be and I think you are
seeing a shift where platforms and you
know governments and whatever they're me
you know maybe they are not necessarily
right about everything and I think
consumers are starting to see that and
you know that's that's displaying itself
in many ways I think consumers are
taking back a degree of control it's a I
think it's a bit of a multitude of
factors like the platforms are having
they're being forced to make new
features like screen time and you know
the new guidelines around safe use and
usage policy and stuff like that they're
being forced to put those changes in
place so while that's going on consumers
as you write them also getting a little
bit savvy er because they've watched
they're going to watch all the
consequences yeah and a funny and
another funny fingers as well as that
you're seeing features that have come
out you know that somebody you know a
group of sort of directors or wherever
they work at you know Facebook have sort
of dreamed up and said oh yeah the world
needs this yeah you seen a lot consumers
say no actually no back off do you
remember when remember when Instagram
updated a bunch of people's apps did you
see this it must have happened here okay
did you see this thing I know what
you're gonna say so Instagram Instagram
sent out an update I think it was to
around about 10 percent to 20 percent of
users and it complete imagine the apps
completely gone and imagine stories feed
that you have to move through
individually one by one and you can't
navigate and they released this update
to like ten or twenty percent of users
and just all hell broke loose it was
meant to be a very very very small task
to like less than 1% of users it
came out over the Christmas break and I
was on our Twitter and I had to report
on it and about an hour later I had to
amend the reports because I said oh my
god Instagram massive update it's
changed my interface yeah it's gone from
a scrolling feed it went from a
scrolling feed to scrolling that way
another speculation that we've been
doing about you know will stories
overtake the news feed it felt like it
was happening literally within the hour
it'd been taken down oh my god I'm
really sorry that test was not meant to
go and we were all left going is that
was that what they're going to change is
it doesn't go that way design it's like
to throw out this new public beta
testing thing where they've actually
invited everyday people you know not
just tech insiders who are connected to
every single yeah I think if you want to
look at a platform that's making changes
for good take a look at what we're doing
because they're being so inclusive of
their updates and they're not just in
people's adorable spam stuff did you
listen to Jack Dorsey on Joe Rogan I
didn't know I will he's done a second
one he came back on a second time today
so he did a first one and Rogan doesn't
usually what I particularly like about
Joe Rogan the reason I think he's a good
podcaster is he just puts his stuff out
like he's effective at what he does the
reason that he's the best podcaster in
the world is because he asks the
question that you would have asked if
you'd had half an hour to prep for that
one section and then he asks it straight
away by riding the crest of now at all
times and constantly asks the best
questions but one of the other reasons I
think he's so good is the fact that he
just doesn't care what people think he
doesn't check the comments on YouTube it
doesn't really respond to stuff like
that but one of the few times Alex Jones
was one of them and Jack Dorsey was
another one
he got so much backlash because people
wanted him to go after Jack Dorsey about
why people get inbound why's Milo the
Unocal is banned why sargon of akkad ban
Y UD platform these people there appears
to be a
leaning bias and all this sort stuff so
is that right [ __ ] it like we're gonna
have jack back on again
then Jack brought his head of the safety
team yeah basically the woman that
presses the ban button and he brought in
Tim Poole who is like the the Ben
Shapiro or he's like the host Gracie of
cutting people down in fast debates in
crellick a like a scalpel precision how
he's able to deploy this stuff and he
came fully armed like study after study
after example after example after
example and during the conversation
sometimes with this especially when you
see Silicon Valley in there you want it
like yes stick it to the man like [ __ ]
the machine yeah and part of me wanted
that that kind of cathartic pleasure
that you get from seeing someone who's
successful just get smashed all over by
someone who's witty hmm like there's
something that I enjoy about that weird
but what ended up happening was a very
Tim continued to be militant throughout
like its parting words were I still
don't like you guys I still don't
believe that what you're doing is for
the greater good and I still hope that
Twitter goes down but thank you for your
timing coming on that was essentially
what he said but throughout the whole
conversation Jack Dorsey CEO of Twitter
and the woman whose name I can't
pronounce on I gonna try who was his
head of the safety team they basically
said we don't understand what this
technology really needs and we are
learning as we go the same way than you
guys are can we have a little bit of
compassion back and there's some things
that seem like there's maybe some double
standards there maybe a little bit more
critical but this degree of compassion
overall I think for people that have had
to deal with high degree of
technological change a lot of financial
ups and downs and the advent of social
media you also I can't say that I want
that for us whilst not also allowing the
executives and the people who were in
the marketing departments to also be
given the same yeah amount of freedom
yeah it's harder to forgive some more
than others
but yeah like I said I'm a really big
fan of what to it was doing because
they'll admit that they're not perfect
and the
they're just being transparent they just
they are really trying to be like open
and honest and inclusive with their
users and yeah they'll get things wrong
but they believe have better intentions
than who goes on Joe Rogan to speak into
millions of people as the CEO of a
company twice and then the second time
knowing that Joe's basically bringing in
your arch your kryptonite with another
person who's the person that is like
public enemy number one essentially to
just have discourse and to try and be as
open as possible I mean that that for
Twitter will have done more than any
advertising campaign candidate and
obviously what did we said before high
risk strategy yeah like you could have
gone on and just fluffed it because
especially at the beginning they're
being very very militant it's it's quite
sort of friction II and they're just
constantly having to swallow this stuff
from Tim as he's just unloading staff to
start out of stuff and you think after a
while you begin to see that that they're
just human beings again the same dude I
mean like the jackdaws he didn't know
what to it was gonna become and I to a
degree I don't believe that Mark
Zuckerberg did like you'd look at him in
those Senate hearings and he's just a
guy that made a website and is now like
oh my god like just looking up at the
sky make this Joe Kelly run I mean maybe
that's what that does just like clammy
and so pale and scared very damp yeah
well I go back to my point because
you're completely right and my my stance
on this will still be okay like you said
you know that this is the medium of
delivery this is the media this is a
technology this is whatever society you
know for the large part we have sort of
put you know what we want to see onto
this you know we need the endless
newsfeed for instance you know and the
scrolling for instance but we started
off as a good idea well they thought
right make a bit money on it but the
problem like the features wouldn't have
stayed if they weren't effective exactly
its natural evolution for the features
that exist on the technology at this
same thing for the reason that the next
episode countdown happens on Netflix is
that it improves retention so more
people watch the rest of the series if
the countdown occurs than if it doesn't
if it was the other way around
if it was the other way around they
wouldn't put it on hmm so your own
choices determine the route of the
technology I think the criticism is we
didn't choose our own cognitive biases
and you are triggering something that's
there in the back of the brain when I
want person to be able to be thinking
about it with this bit and you like okay
so but guys it's been absolutely
fantastic thank you so much for going so
next time I will be on that couch do you
both sit here guys link to social minds
podcast will be in the show notes below
link to all of the stuff of social chain
will be there as well don't forget to
press share if you enjoyed this and if
you've got any comments about what we've
brought today fire them in the comments
on YouTube really appreciate it guys
thank you again thank you
[Music]